hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute geht's seit langem
endlich mal wieder eine leckere suppe
ich glaube meine letzte show ferrari für
bis zu vier und die kam ja bereits im
herbst seit wir haben fast den
kompletten winter überstanden ohne ein
leckeres rezept und deswegen finde ich
es jetzt an der zeit für eine leckere
karotten suppe und ich werde die nicht
alleine servieren sondern es gibt dazu
leckere käse klößchen oder so käser
bälle
die werden aus einem leckeren brunch
teig gemacht und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten für die these
bändchen die bereitet nämlich zuerst zu
damit sie einfach schon backen können
und dann werden wir gleich die super
machen
ich brauche für die käse welche 100
milliliter wasser 20 gramm butter
ich hab mir den halben teelöffel salz 70
gramm mehl 80 gramm käse ich habe jetzt
hier ein paar mühsam käse genommen und
habe den einfach frisch gerieben
da könnte aber auch zum beispiel in
gouda oder einen anderen nehmen
aber der parmesan käse schmeckt einfach
richtig witzig dann brauche ich ein
und ich nehme noch einen teelöffel
thymian einfach so für die würze dessen
jetzt die zutaten für die käse bettchen
und ich zeige euch auch gleich noch die
zutaten für die suppe dann haben nämlich
alles gleich durch das ich auch ganz
wenig ich brauche etwas olivenöl so etwa
zwei esslöffel dann brauche ich eine
zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe die müsste hier
irgendwo liegen aber ich sehe sie nicht
hier ein stück ingwer dann habe ich hier
600 milliliter gemüsebrühe pfeffer ich
benutze curry und chili zum würzen und
ich brauch später etwa 40 milliliter
schlagsahne und natürlich die hauptzutat
hier meine karotten dessen jetzt 550
gramm und geschält sollten es etwa 500
gramm werden
so jetzt starten wir einfach direkt mit
dem rezept ich habe natürlich einen topf
vergessen rauszuholen aber hier ist ja
direkt und zwar nehme ich dafür jetzt
einfach einen ganz kleinen topf gestellt
ist einfach mal hier drauf und aus
brandtag werden übrigens auch windbeutel
hergestellt die ich auch in kürzester
zeit mal herstellen werde
aber ich habe irgendwie noch nicht die
gelegenheit dazu ich gebe jetzt mein
wasser und meine mutter in dem topf und
stark kommt auch direkt salz mit rein
und jetzt wird erst mal die butter in
dem wasser aufgelöst und dieser typ
heißt brandtag weil wir den gleich im
topf anbrennen werden aber das hat
und sobald sich die butter gelöst hat
gebe ich jetzt auf einen sprung des
komplette mail mit rein und das muss man
jetzt kräftig rühren sich ein kleiner
kraftakt bis sich alles zu einem
homogenen teig verbunden hat und jetzt
wo ich das hier so lange bis wir gleich
einen weißen belag auf dem posten das
heißt dann einfach dass der teig
abgebrannt ist und dann können wir ihn
vom herd unternehmen müsste halt rühren
rühren rühren damit sich keine klümpchen
bilden
und man sieht jetzt schon den weißen
belag am topf hier am boden
aber ich will jetzt einfach ein bisschen
weil ich nur aktive habe und jetzt
schalte ich den herd aus neben einen
teig heraus also ihr seht ist hier ganz
gut das ist jetzt ein richtig zerteilt
und hier unten am rand habe ich einfach
diese weise kruste jetzt dran und ich
gebe den teig jetzt in der größere
schüssel am besten einfach so eine
glasschüssel zum beispiel und verteilt
ihn ein bisschen denn wenn er jetzt so
als close etwas abkühlen muss dann baut
das natürlich ein bisschen länger
ich verteile sieht so ein bisschen am
rand entlang dann geht es einfach viel
schneller und zu lange da ist ganz kurz
abkühlen kann denn jetzt kann ich das
einfach nicht dazu geben sonst gerinnt
das anteilig kaputt aber ich lasse es
etwa fünf minuten abkühlen und die zeit
nutze ich jetzt einfach um eine karotten
zu schälen
inzwischen ist das etwas abgekühlt so
ein bisschen lauwarm darf er schon noch
sein und ihr zweites einrühren und weil
es mir halt einfach sehr schwierig geht
nehme ich jetzt einfach den mixer und
macht es damit ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel ein handrührgerät mit knethaken
nehmen das habe ich leider nicht und die
große küchenmaschine schmerzte groß
deswegen jetzt einfach mit dem mixer
kurz einrühren
dann sieht das ganze etwa so aus und
jetzt gebe ich da einfach nicht den
käsereien und thymian und lass es noch
mal kurz vor mixen bestand stadtteil
schon fertig
jetzt nehme ich mein agent s klasse und
macht den in einem glas wasser nass und
stelle ich mir da jetzt vom teig zu
kleine stücke ab die sind jetzt so etwa
walnussgroße können auch die finger ein
bisschen nass machen und das ganze zu
runden welchen formen aus dem teig
entstehen jetzt so etwa 20 bis 25 stück
die selbst sich jetzt hier auf dem
backblech mit einer folie immer mal
wieder finger nass machen sonst geht
nämlich das normalerweise spritzt man ja
so einen brand stark er mit so einem
spritzbeutel gerade wenn man jetzt
windbeutel macht aber wir machen krise
bändchen drauf deswegen machen wir das
bei mir sind jetzt ganz genau 25 käse
pfännchen und die kommen jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei ober
unterhitze 220 grad für etwa 13 bis 15
minuten offen bis sie schön goldbraun
werden und die zwischenzeit nutze ich
jetzt um eine super zuzubereiten
zuerst nehme ich jetzt meine zwiebel und
die knoblauchzehe und hattet ihr einfach
ganz grob wir werden hier die super
später sowieso pürieren und deswegen
muss das jetzt nicht ganz so hauser
denn irgendwann nämlich jetzt den
schädel jetzt nicht ganz sondern ich
schreib einfach mit dem löffel hier also
mit seinem kleinen teelöffel einfach so
ein bisschen die schale ab aber auch nur
da wo die schale einfach hart ist die
irgendwann schale ist sehr dünn da muss
man da auch nicht so verschwenderisch
sein oder ihr schält sie großzügig und
nehmt dann zum beispiel die schale um
den tee zu machen
das können dann natürlich auch machen
und denen dann einfach auch ganz grob
hacken
und jetzt gebe ich das schon gemeinsam
mit meinem olivenöl also mit zwei
esslöffeln in einem großen topf und
erhitzt den top und laster alles jetzt
glasig dünsten
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die karotten kleinen stücke einfach
so in scheiben schneiden und hier dünner
jetzt da die scheiben sind umso
schneller kochen die karotten eben auch
da
und dann möchte ich das ganze einfach
mit der gemüsebrühe ab und lass es
gleich aufkochen und sobald kocht geben
wir einfach noch die karotten mit dazu
die karotten durften bei mir jetzt etwa
eine viertelstunde lang in der brühe
kochen und jetzt sind sie weich und
jetzt wird die suppe einfach nur noch
püriert mit einem pürierstab
ich spüre jetzt die suppe nicht komplett
deutsch damit ich einfach nur zum park
rotten stücken mit drin habe ich finde
es immer ganz schön wenn man noch ein
bisschen gemüse zu beweisen hat so als
zimmer zähne sind auch noch gut und
kühlten 1001 wird kommt nicht mit rein
mord auch 2015 lassen wir manche
gerichte vegetarisch so wenn euch die
suppe jetzt zu dick ist weil zum
beispiel zu viel wasser verdampft ist
gibt da einfach nur ein bisschen wasser
rein
ich gebe jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
sahne rein also wie vorhin erwähnt etwa
40 milliliter 40-50 muss aber auch nicht
sein dass können via kalorienarm seien
ganz genau und wenn sie euch dann noch
zu dick lebte einfach mal wasser rein
und lust auf kochen so ich würde jetzt
das ganze und schmeckt es ab mit etwas
pfeffer
ich habe es hier unten pfeffer den hat
mir mal aus der türkei mitgebracht finde
ich immer ganz lecker aber ihr könnt
auch ganz normal schwarzenberger nehmen
meine in kaluga player deswegen der
bunte und am besten immer frischen
pfeffer weile einfach viel aromatisch
schmeckt das aroma von pfeffer geht auch
nicht so schnell verloren wie wenn ihr
jetzt bereits fertig gemahlen nehmt dann
wird sich das ganze natürlich mit chili
ich mag gerne in die suppe etwas
schärfer sinn
aber ich nehme zu viel wegen monat und
bis sie in curry
und ich schmeckt es gleich jetzt nochmal
ab morath darf gleich probieren und ich
wollte euch jetzt erstmal noch die käse
bändchen zeigen die ich jetzt bereits
fertig gebacken habe die habe ich jetzt
hier angerichtet auf inseln kleines
schildchen und dann kann man die sich
geld nehmen und so super mit dazu essen
es freut mich dass ich halt der parmesan
käse der da einfach so dominant dann
auch schmeckt ja stimmt kann eigentlich
auch so als snack machen mit zb einem
joghurt dip dann kann man die auch das
eintippen nämlich auch ganz gut
vorstellen
also ich würde meine suppe noch ein
bisschen bisschen schäfer hatte ich gebe
dann auch gleich ein bisschen salz mit
rein und stanser wir ich gleich diese
falsch und jetzt sage ich nur eine suppe
wie gesagt ihr könnt sie gerne etwas
dünner machen ich mag es gerne wenn es
ein bisschen dicker ist und mit leckeren
stückchen drin und ich gebe es nun
wieder trüber einfach auch für die optik
sind chili m hoch
ich da noch ein bisschen grün drauf
einfach basilikum und ihr seht ich hab
das sonst auch gar nicht gewürzt also
mit anderen kreuz haben kann man
natürlich auch machen aber ich finde der
geschmack von der chaotische einfach so
schön süßlich und passt einfach gut zu
dem chili bis hin zum curry und so kann
ich dies so die super praktisch
servieren und muratow darf ich dir
gleich mal probieren
mit käse war genau
bin ich mal gespannt gemacht werden du
hast nicht vermischt
das war mal ein schöner teller den
wollte ich noch fotografieren
hallo also das super schmeckt echt gut
mit dem käse bisschen dazu und ich würde
sagen ich denke jetzt einen neuen
tellerrand ist noch ein foto schießen
kann für instagram da hat sich übrigens
auch sally stewart und der murat hat
sogar auch ein instagram account monat
wenn du dich wie will michael kelly
smith ganz gern nichts wurde
aber ich finds gut wir sehen uns einfach
beim nächsten mal wieder ihr könnt auch
gern dem rat folgen und auch mir gerne
einen kommentar hinterlassen
ihr könnt mir immer schreiben ob ihr
euch vielleicht nochmal ansuchen rezept
wünscht oder ob es jetzt bei euch die
suppen saison so ein bisschen fertig ist
wenn er jetzt bald der frühling auch
wieder kommt das wird mich ganz arg
interessieren und ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr mir da einfach einen kommentar
ab wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder und das rezept gibt es auch celle
- blog.de